gerald mccoy also big cat had this
statement to espn he's now with the
cowboys he's been with the buccaneers
and then with the panthers now with the
cowboys he said the cowboys the most
recognized franchise in the world it
would be great to hear a statement from
the cowboys great to hear
a statement from jerry jones in support
of everything that's going on will that
get me in trouble to say that
i don't know but the truth
is it needs to be said the problem is
people are afraid to have the
conversations and i'll tell you what
that hits close to home for jerry jones
he's been called out by richard sherman
and others outside the organization for
not saying anything over the last three
and a half weeks and really when does
three and a half weeks go by that jerry
jones says nothing now someone on his
team is saying we need you to make a
statement about everything that's going
on good for gerald mccoy and the clock
continues to tick on when jerry jones is
going to make something that he believes
that he feels that he has decided to do
known to the world
yeah good for jerome mccoy but uh it
will be interesting if there's private
discussions because jerry jones i mean
can you remember the last time that
someone has spoken out like that against
jerry not against jerry jones but at
least uh pushed back at jerry jones from
with inside the cowboys uh walls and
maybe it's because joe mccoy is new
there and he doesn't feel beholden to
anyone but i i like that he's speaking
out because i think players
as a whole should have uh the ability to
criticize their owners criticize their
you know their general manager maybe not
to a you know to a point obviously but
players should have the freedom to be
able to speak their mind when it comes
to any of these issues and uh we'll see
what happens i i mean do you think
jerry's probably
behind the scenes a little upset
well i i you know what this is one of
those moments where you just don't care
people need to say what needs to be said
and the fact that jerry jones and very
few of the owners have had anything to
say the coaches have been the ones who
have come out and said we support
players who decide to kneel for the
national anthem i want to hear the
owners come out and say we support the
active deliberate effort to choose what
you're going to do conscientiously what
will you be doing during the anthem we
support you to make that decision we
support you to implement whatever
decision you make and there will be no
repercussions of any kind there will be
no benching there will be no limited
playing time there will be no lack of a
contract extension you won't be cut
before week one of the regular season if
you kneel during the preseason you're a
guy who's otherwise on the fringe that's
the kind of stuff that is missing and
jerry jones isn't the only one big cat
think about it how many owners have we
heard from
on these core issues that have been
discussed by so many players over the
last three weeks
well i mean there's a reason why jerry
jones has said uh none of those things
because none of those things are true
right so and now we're in a spot where
if
you want jerry jones to say he won't cut
anyone for kneeling
i don't even know if i want him to say
that because i don't think it would be
true and then i don't want him to go
so yeah right right
i don't want i don't i want i don't want
the owners to to lie to people and lie
to the fans and lie to the players just
to say something to say something
so in a backwards way i guess jerry
jones good job for not lying to us even
though
uh you should probably listen to your
players here
implicit in my comment is they need to
mean it when they say it right i'm sorry
if i wasn't clear on that i'm not saying
they just need to say it for the words
to echo right through the internet i i'm
saying this is what they need to believe
and i think the statement from the
commissioner from a couple of weeks ago
has kind of generally led us to believe
that's what they believe but still i
think we need something more concrete in
this moment and i have no problem with
any players standing up and exercising
their prerogative to speak we saw it
this week with chuba hubbard from
oklahoma state when he didn't like
something mike gundy did and i think
that players in the nfl should feel
emboldened to follow suit and if
something is happening that they are
troubled by they need to say so and if
anyone has a problem with that it is
their
problem
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports